hi everyone they never just started the
session today so today i'm going to
share running your first automatic
speech recognition model on hacking
phase
so i'm mia chan i'm from aws work as a
machine learning specialist solution
architect what i do for my daily work is
i talk with the customers around a
machine learning workload on ads best
practice and i also do some enablement
with my customers and also a developer
community community
so today before i start the talk i would
like to ask your experience on the audio
machine learning so how many of you
already work with audio data on your
machine learning project raise your hand
let me know
one two
okay great i think that's great audience
because i put to the first right so that
means you're probably from zero to one
or from one to one point two something
like that so
um so for this talk i prepare for the
people
for interesting on machine learning
topics audio machine learning topics and
also probably you're interested in the
hacking phase the framework that i will
introduce later so let's dive into the
content today
so for the agenda first i will show you
what is the asr that is automatic speech
recognition and later on i will share my
experience from how i work with audio
data and then i will share what's the
model that today we are going to
fine-tune
on and also the data set that you can
play around with
and also i will share some code snippets
on how you can do it with hacking face
on amazon stage maker the end of it we
can go through how to interact with the
endpoint or test your model and in the
end i will share you after the sessions
if you want to try it out what could be
next it could be where to start coding
where to find more resources and so on
so this is my agenda that i will go
through
yeah so persecution here i assume
everyone is interested in python that's
why i'm here you are out here and also
later on i will share the gp lab um have
you worked with jupiter lab drip
notebook raise your hand let me know
okay my friend that's great
and probably you are interested in
machine learning and nlp so that's my
three prerequisites for this topic
so to start to talk about asr
for asr this
term probably most of you feel like not
so familiar with what it is
and there is a more friendly name
it can called speech to text so when it
comes to speech to text it makes it more
friendly right you understand what it
actually do and where we can use it in
the real live application so i put four
examples here
first you can use it to analysis your
custom service call so from some
customers that i work with they want to
know what their customers are
complaining about so first they need to
capture the audio and later on after
capture the audio they put it into a
speech to text get the text content and
do sentiment analysis or test
classification or intent classification
to analysis the content later and the
second case could be the voice a system
like alessa like siri they are the
service that take your voice as input
and make it to speech to text and make
it more friendlier for your computer to
understand what you are saying and then
put it into like instructions in
application and then they book the hotel
room for you they do other things for
you as your voice a system
the last two um i put it here for
video subtitling and also transcribing
the meetings
this two use case is the one that i like
the most why because originally when we
are going to manage the video content
it's really hard to just find the
correct video content just by search
because it's really hard to just search
a video without knowing what is in that
in content so for people who are doing
content management it's really difficult
if you don't know what the content it is
and for people who cannot hear anywhere
they need subtitle to help them
understand what's the content in the
video so these are the four use cases i
list here probably you can think more
when you start your first a's or project
now i want to move to the next slide
work with audio data so i also
want to use this talk to share my
journey i remember when i first started
the machine learning project it was a
while ago but
after some time then i finally start my
first audio data what took it so long
because i feel that i'm not familiar
with audio data probably some of you
also feel me like this one like for me
first i feel comfortable to work with
tableau data image data because i can
just see this as it is
and for the audio data i don't know how
to work with it and later on as soon as
i work with more and more audio data
project i found out
one thing that really helps me is to
visualize it when you see it this one is
only one sample right but when you work
with audio data you might work with
human speaking like i'm speaking or you
heard a dog is barking and then the wave
of it when you visualize it actually is
different and even i saw the interesting
research is when we are speaking in
different languages like my mother
tongue is monitoring so when i speak in
mandarin like the sound wave is a bit
how i speak in english so the different
way that shows the different features
and characteristics in each of the audio
file and that really helps me when i do
like audio classification that i know if
they looks differently they should be
categorized differently right and this
is how we got intuition when we work
with image data or computer vision data
that's how we get
the intuition on it and i apply this
intuition when i work with audio data
that's how i started and another one is
i take one example it's the hacking
phase so hacking phase libraries
it's
a startup that they focus on the
language use case and recently they get
more adopted computer vision case as
well
on
hoganface website you can find
model you can find datasets you can find
other people are sharing how they use
this data set and this model to do their
projects so this has really helped me to
see how other people are using audio
data to do their project because
sometimes we don't start it could be
first you feel really far from the
project or the second one is
you don't have the idea what are you
going to do with audio data so that's
where i got my inspiration from so
probably later on when you start it you
can also visit hiking face website to
see it
so i want to dive deep a bit about what
is hacking face libraries so when you
visit their website you will see
it's a open source
data sets transformers tokenizers that
you can use it in your project
and it's also a popular library since it
has more than
65 000 github stars and tons of
downloads per month so with this a few
data points i would like to show you if
you would like to work on some nlp
project no matter is text analysis or
like audio analysis this could be the
place you can start to play around with
it so it depends on your work
environment if you are the one that
happy work on your computer then open
source from work that you can just work
on your computer right and if you are
the one like me i'm working on some
cloud environment you can also run this
workload on the cloud environment as
well it really depends on
which text stack that you're familiar
with
so before i dive into the code sample i
just want to highlight like when you
starting work using parking phase to
start your first ace or model what are
the things that you might need
first i'm sharing you need to start
initiate an estimator so when you start
to initiate estimator that shows where
you can find the training script where
you can find your source code or your
source data and what are the computer
powers that later on you're going to run
on your training job so these are the
details that you might want to put in
there and then when you start training
the model you just run hugging phase
estimator
and feet
so
it's like other projects that you work
with psyche learn you have the estimator
and then the feet then you will start
training
okay
any questions so far
oh good
okay then i will switch my monitor to
the
notebook one
i hope
you can see well
do i need to zoom in a bit i think for
the the image part should be fine though
for people in the last line i see you're
nodding that's great
and so this notebook
and the content that i shared today is
one of the artifacts that from my
colleagues and i did the tech review for
the time content for this and i think
this will be a great start point for
people who
want to start your audio project so
let's start from the background what is
the model that we use as a base model to
fine tune with
so the base model is called web 2 vector
what it does under the hood i shared it
for this pictures the first you have the
roll audio it's like the wave like this
one
and then later on we will send the audio
file to the feature encoder
so after you got the feature encoders
that makes it from the original audio
file to
the vectors that computer can understand
later on you bring these features to
transformers to do the context network
and got the tokens for ctc algorithm
later
and
what i really like is later on if you
want to dive deep on what is ctc you can
click
the link that later i can share in the
slack to dive deep on what's under the
hood for ctc algorithm
and why i like this algorithm is when
you prepare the speech-to-text
data you only need to provide audio and
transcription and you don't need to
provide the time stamp
is it awesome right because you don't
need to annotate it till like which
second that i speech which word you only
need to just end to end like one audio
file what's the contents that i speak so
i think this is a really great star for
people who are lazy for annotation and
then this is a good way to start working
with ctc and for ctc
it's not only work when it comes along
speech to text it also works when you
are doing handwriting recognition
so
remember like in the beginning of the
talk i'm mentioning when work with audio
data i also take my experience when i
work with computer vision projects
that's also applied here when you see
the ctc algorithms it's algorithm that
apply both audio use cases and
handwriting recognition which comes from
computer vision use case so you can use
your previous knowledge to learn how to
start an audio project like this one
okay
and later on what are the components
that within this notebook
it's about first we will load a data set
okay
and for the data set itself it comes
along it's called speech processing
universal performance benchmark
it comes along with
i remembers like hundreds of hours
let me click this one to type deep
so
the website that you're seeing right now
is the hacking waste website
and then if you go to data sets that you
can find here
for each of the data set
on the hacking face page you will find
several things
first what is this data set
about
another one is what you can do with the
several data sets so for instance in our
case will be automatic speech
recognition sr so that means if you want
to run an asr task you can use this data
set and also come along with other
audio tasks like keyword sparting or
other audio classification and so on so
in the dataset page you can always find
several tasks here
and
test a category here
and most importantly
is the language
um the case that i share today is
dedicated for the english case and i
know since we are in europe right now so
they are like multi language in europe
so there are some data sets that come
along with multi-language support and
for this data set it's dedicated for
english case
okay let's go back to the notebook
so first this is our data set come along
with tons of audio files and then later
on we are going to use a tokenizers
to make it as a separate alphabet and
then run the feature extractor to make
it more friendlier for computer to
understand it and later on start a
training script
uh split our data set to the trending
and test data and later on you can use
hacking phase dlc deep learning
container when you deploy it then you
can run
model input and prediction and output
in the end of it you can have endpoint
which is the model as an inference that
you can use to serve your external users
so this are the end-to-end process for
this one
okay
to start
i will need to start a corner for this
yes
oh please
could you elaborate a little bit more on
the um
uh i think in the earlier
diagram you had it labeled as cnn but i
think it's the bit which does the
uh pre-processing
you just elaborate on what's going on in
that box please
and so it'll be the one
which is labeled here as cnn
yes um
if you can just explain
just briefly what's going on in terms of
how you do the future extraction please
um in that
yeah sure please thank you so
um for the feature extractor that um you
can think of like from the audio file
itself originally it come along with the
waves that we see in the graph and then
in the feature encoder usually what we
will do for the pre-processing sometimes
we will do furious transformer some
mathematic class that you might left in
your like college
and then
later on when after you do the
transformation that you got a series of
the vectors and then later on uh depends
on the
uh the model that you run with
sorry about that
okay depends on the model that you run
with after you run the
pre-processing and later on you want to
run that encoder and then encoder
depends on which encoder that you run to
it will become encoded to different
dimensions of the vectors so it really
depends on the use case and also depends
on the network that you're going to run
later so for instance later on if we are
going to call the transformers then
there is an input dimension for the
transformers right so in the feature
encoder that you have to make sure your
uh
output of this encoder is the input for
the the context network so it's kind of
like
um i would say the
feature encoder or pre-processing is
kind of like
hacking way because first you will
select which model you want to work with
and then you work based on the input
that you need and then you
kind of you know to twitch the the audio
file to the the input that you need for
that so that would be the things that
you need to do
in this part you don't need to convert
the audio file to text because this part
still
applies that from the audio wave that
all the numbers that you got and then
convert to vectors so this part is only
the
audio file itself and later on when you
work with transformers and ctc that's
where you come along with the
transcription that is your labor data
okay
so i
um get my kernel started
so because our session is only like 41
minutes and this model if you run at
home it will take two hours for training
i will not wait here for three hours i
think you will also um so what i will do
is kind of like the cooking show way so
if you have watched the cooking shows
you always see like someone cutting the
onions and then later on they said oh
i'm going to wait for the onion to be
cooked and they just put the cakes on
there because that's something that they
made before so that's also what i would
do today is like the cooking show i will
show you first how it's drawn and when
it goes to training part i would just
stop there and bring something that is
precooked and then you can know how it
works uh in general
so
um i don't know if the last
last row of people that you can see it
clearly i can just briefly go through
what i do for each of the the code block
here
usually first you specify which
libraries that you're going to use which
is like sage makers and transformers and
also libraries
torch libraries that later on our use
and for the
the browser this one is libraries if you
want to work with audio data
and later on uh you also need the file
that you can work with the audio file as
well
and what i do in this
code block is using
the sagemaker sessions which is the
service that i'm running right now to
get my session so that i can use it to
interact with aws s3 or other storage
that i put my data in
it will take some time since it's still
doing the environment setup here
regarding the data pre-processing uh
regarding the question that you ask
there are like two parts for instance
all the data that you got from online
they probably not
for your own purpose they probably just
put there for everyone can use it so
when you download this data set you
found there are actually
a few schemas that you are not using it
so you only select the features that you
need
so that um
the rest of the the features can be done
by that so for instance in this of the
data sets
they have i remember is four five or six
columns on it but then we only need two
or three of it for each of the speakers
what content they speak and so on
and later on we also do the trend test
split here regarding the tesla size is
0.2 you can always change later
and then you can also print it out to
see what's the data set the trend the
first entry will look like
a second
okay so each row you can see i'm not
sure if you can really clearly but i can
walk you through each of the data point
in this data set the first will show you
where is the data where's the file path
next what's the array
the array that is the value for that and
what's the sampling rate the sampling
rate is 16 000 hertz and this one would
be people if you work with audio data
set the usc help people doing the sample
rate differently some people were doing
16 000 some people were doing like 8 000
depends on the data resources that you
have and remember if you are doing the
sample rating 16 000 here for your
training set when you deploy your model
to production remember
when you got to the new data you should
also resemble it as the host that you
have here so that you can have the best
performance for your model
okay so let's work through the data
points
and here i put a little bit mathematics
on formulae here
that i just want to share
this cdc model is good for both speech
recognition and hierarchy recognition
and what it does is as you know for the
handwriting they are like
continuous the handwriting when you do
it that's the same when you are speaking
a word like when i'm speaking the word
that actually
let's say
if i say a word that's a method so it's
like math it's like
sorry i don't know how to disconnect it
probably also cannot right and how we
speak and how we write they just
continuously put the data point together
so these algorithms help us can separate
them so even i said method but later on
it can separate this m-e-t-h-o-d
for this case and then for the
handwritten one as well if you write
method then this algorithm can help you
separate it a separate alphabet
okay
and then here we do the extract
information
here what it actually does let me open
a vocab
json file so because i mentioned for the
ctc algorithm it will make continuous
audio file to
each of the alphabet so you need each of
the alphabet here as encoding and also
there are some parts or unrecognized
ones so that later on when you work with
it
you can have
space in the middle or you can have
um
like the the blank token in the middle
so it's the one
blank and unknown
so this are the token that we are
talking about right now
and after we got it
on the json file later on we will run
through the transformers for tokenizers
and feature extractor so this is where
the transformers run through the file
that you'd have and try to
have the tokenized and extracted
features so that you can run it later in
your training set
training set
seems will take some time
yeah
when it's still loading i want to share
one thing is um so for the audio project
that usually it will come alone with a
few
audio sample data and most of the data
that comes along with the combination of
different
let's say men and women
kids or elders like when you are picking
the data set itself you are actually
picking up the different combination of
the data points that you collect so
be mindful with the data that you pick
not necessarily reflect the data points
that you have from your upcoming new
customers so
from the the previous uh session i think
was from theodos talked about like
testing stuff and when we wrote out a
machine learning product on production
that's also something you might want to
be aware of the data that you trend is
kind of ideal environment and you
probably have
equally class for each of the users like
25
for
kids uh 25 for teenagers 25 percent for
people mid age and elders so you have it
equally but when you launch in
production and probably like 70 of the
users are kids so their pitch on really
high is
like not the normal pitch that we have
also like adults right so once you find
something it goes differently as you
expect it's on production then you can
always reevaluate it to think is this
the correct data set to start with or we
already got to the new data point so
that we can update our modulator so the
machine learning project it's not like
make one and you just put there for 100
years it's more like you make one you
test one and then when you put on
production you continuously monitoring
to make sure it fits your user's need
okay this one takes like the ages i've
already talked about like roller
production things and still in 23
so i would just continuing not blocked
by this one
um
yeah the data set is not defined yet
because from here
okay
i will go through
the code part
for
when you start this training block what
happening under the hood i take amazon
stage maker example and you'll feel free
to kind of change this code to whatever
platform that you're working on
one that works under the hood is
taking the estimator that hugging face
estimator with the framework that we
just mentioned with two vector and then
put it as a container that stagemaker
will start a training job which is start
some instance remotely start your
training job and during the same time
you can
close this browser because that's a job
be created remotely and then after you
finish the training you can go to
the place that check your training job
to see if they are
complete so you can always come back
and
revisit when your model training is done
the training script here it comes along
with the script and trend
so
if you are the one that interesting on
what happened under the hood feel free
to visit this trend in the pi file
in here it covers what are the
tokenizers what are the things that we
take care for like the model setup and
training setup
and here are the metrics that we run
through that for
the sr recognition and the trainer and
the model and so on so this will be
the code snippets later on you might
want to visit too
was that questions or just stretching
yeah i was just seeing someone like
relaxing that's good
um
so
uh
till the end
let's assume our training now starts
and then
after
we run this estimate the fit
after two hours you got your model trend
what happened afterwards then you need a
snips for
deploy your model to endpoint
when you deployed it what you need to
make it happen
first mention about what are the codes
that you want to run on as an inference
where you can find the model artifacts
and
what are the transformation versioning
pi torch versioning that you use and in
the end you will have an endpoint of it
and
in the end you can also have
the audio file here that you can test it
out with your endpoint
so um the idea will be when we go
through it um the web file that you can
always turn on
from i think from this one
let me check
she had your dark suit in greasy wash
water all year
so when tried it out with the audio
flight here then to the endpoint as a
predictor that shows
the
transcription under here so the idea
will be when you fight to the model the
output of it is should be the
transcription of the audio file you just
put in remember
if you trend with the dot web file it
should come along with that web file if
you're trying alone with 16 000 hertz
file you need to resample your data to
the same huds so that can be a best
performance these are just the minor
things i would like to just call it out
um
now this is
the the end to end code samples snippets
here any question regarding the code
samples
no not yet okay so later on i can share
this code sampled in our slack channel
so that later when you go through if you
have any questions you can reach out to
me offline
and another thing that i would like to
share
is
the notebook
so
from the conversation that we have
actually i've already got through most
of the things i would like to share
what is asr i hope you have the clear
idea what is sr4 and what are the
application that you can find as model
within it
and perhaps in your mind you already
start to think about how you're going to
use asr
in your
side project
and later on i share a few tips about
when you load the data set what are the
things that you might need to notice
and what are the things that you can um
check especially like from the hiking
phase estimator how to start it how to
start a training job and in the end to
interact with the endpoint and for me
what interested me the most is like
before
uh today's conference like yesterday i
also mentioned this
conference to my colleagues and
mentioned about i'm going to share uh
ace art model using hugging face and
using english model and then my
colleagues who work with french
customers then we start to to find the
resources can we also adopt this one to
our german customer and also french
customer i think that would be super
cool to see the next step for this one
and how about the multi-language asr
if you
go to visit the hacking face website you
will see the model itself the web 2
vector itself is only for one single
language but also there are other models
that you can apply for multi-language
acer and i think that's super cool
because before
if you need to trend a model for one
specific language that you probably
would need to like manage smart models
and later on if you got the chance to
have a multi-language asr then probably
you can
have one model and
apply for several use cases so these are
the open topic i don't have like the
best answer right now because the use
case time share is with english so
really happy to dive deep if you have
any question on the session or later on
if you try it out other language like
german french i don't know italian or
portuguese
other use case feel free to share with
me and then i put several learning
resources here the learning resources
contained a few github samples where you
can start with where you can find a blog
post where you can dive deep on the
stagemaker hacking phase documentation
include api details what other
parameters you need to put in and also
the more posts on hacking phase on aws
so for me the most interested me is now
we see more and more like open source
from work that actually brings awesome
knowledge about using nlp computer
vision audio machine learning and so on
so i think it's really great to see the
different frameworks and you can have
the capacity to run locally or things on
cloud
so these are the posts and resources
that i'm sharing
and this is the last slide if you want
to reach out to me the qr code to link
info file and thank you everyone
uh thank you very much mia for the talk
are there any questions
thanks for the talk um yeah okay
um
just wanted to know um what the latency
of the asr model was on this for hosting
it virus sagebreaker endpoint
yeah
for this one it would depend on
your payload that means how much seconds
that you send over and for the case like
the one that i just showed i think it's
within three seconds so you can see it
responds quite fast and if you have like
uh
several minutes or hours then you
probably would consider it if you want
to like chant it as a small amount so
that you can do it in parallel and got
the whole transcription back faster so
it depends on the payload that you send
over
thank you very much for the talk um a
very brief question um any challenges in
how to label your data you know for for
training
yeah um i see the challenges there would
be um one case that i found in in europe
actually we are from everywhere like for
instance i'm from taiwan so when i work
i speak english with my like taiwanese
accent and then that's also the case
that some of my customers mentioned
about
they are building a model for italian
extend english model so the accent topic
is kind of a challenge that i generally
see right now right because for the data
that i just showed you is perfect
english it's from u.s english or uk
english mercury you can find however
like in europe in general that's what i
see as one challenge another one is as
you mentioned like what are the things
that stop us to do annotation and things
like that
the cdc model that i referring to is
already the minimum offer you need to
prepare because you don't need to map
the timestamp and also the audio file so
this already made the annotation lives
way more easier however the accent part
i don't have like right answer yet
probably i don't know we need to have a
room let everyone in the room speak
something on that and then we make a
huge data slide together um yeah
um we're running out of time so just one
more question
thank you very much for the talk um it's
a slight
diversion maybe but i'm curious because
i've been going into nlp relatively
recently and this was a lovely
introduction because i've never done
anything with live
live audio
in i can see that i could use this to
get the transcription to try and do
something like
a motion sentiment analysis on the other
end but i'm thinking there's also
information in the way somebody said it
so i'm curious is there any models that
you're aware of that will start to
project of this is an angry caller
coming through just from the intonation
not just the literal language they use
that's a good call out um
actually when we said uh sentiment
analysis like usually we do
speech to text and then analysis
what these people say literally by word
right but sometimes we can talk
differently like
hey i really hate you
and it's like
which one
i'm happy
i really hate you or somewhat so i also
find that this is really challenging
regarding to content management for
instance if you have kids at home you
probably will play some video clips for
them but there are some like
um
youtube videos that are playing the
things like what i just referring to
oh i'm so happy today i'm going to kill
the person and
the the parents they're not aware of
that the herder sounds is like happy
sounds but what they said literally the
parents just you know watch the dish
behind they don't aware of what's the
context out there so when we do the
content analysis it's important to do
both so the audio emotion plus what's
the sentiment under the hood and you do
chris check and make the life is more
real word instead of like you're just
guessing these people is happy or not
and also bring along the context
sometimes because sometimes people will
speak opposite
when you just analysis from a single
sentence but if you do the parallel over
the conversation context then you know
when people say this sentence is based
on this context so you have a positive
possibility possibly positive negative
is it really negative or it's kind of
they are presenting their positive in
different way so bring the context along
would also help to that
all right thank you very much mia any
questions you can just talk to her
[Applause]